I love collaborating with Marvel they're
so open to collaboration and they also
just meanwhile have the best ideas so
I'm happy with wherever the road takes
me I trust them immensely while the sacs
list of superheroes and villains is
still being confirmed Thor Ragnarok
Tessa Thompson may be joining forces as
Valkyrie in Avengers infinity war the
next Marvel film that's coming out that
everyone is excited about is Avengers
infinity war
what is one word that you would describe
as far as an emotion that people are
gonna feel when they walk out of that
film what can you t oh my gosh I think
galvanized you know yeah I think
galvanized it's the thing that I feel
way before I was ever in the the Marvel
Cinematic Universe before I dreamt that
I ever would be is that their characters
are you know an epic proportion super
here these superheroes these godlike
characters and also meanwhile incredibly
human I've always felt like the strength
of Marvel films are not just you know
the action sequences which of course we
love is audience members but really
dynamically that action that happens
between these characters they're our
friendships their love stories their
loss I think those are the things that
really tug on your heart and make you
and make you compelled to really follow
characters on their journey so I think
the same thing will be true in Avengers
infinity war and the truth is I think
the same thing will be true throughout
phase 4 because that's what Marvel does
best
you